[Music]
hey what's up guys I'm cabby HD here and
in a strange series of events in an odd
timeline Apple has now officially
canceled the air power wireless charging
mat it's totally dead the project is
over there is no replacement it's done
and it's so bizarre just because I mean
it didn't have to be a big deal at all
it's just a wireless charging that in
theory but it became this big deal and
became very strange because of the way
things played out and because of what
air power was supposed to be so air
power was originally announced way back
with the iPhone 10 back two years ago in
2017 and it was supposed to be while I
was charging that in white you've
probably seen pictures of it that would
charge the iPhone the air pods and your
Apple watch all at the same time and
because it was made by Apple other
third-party stuff couldn't do this but I
would have this sweet iOS integration
where it would show the charging
percentage of all the things on the mat
all on iOS on the iPhone so it'll been
this pretty nifty solution for people
who owned all three things this is not
possible with current standards but our
team knows how to do this we call it air
power so look for the air power charger
next year so that was September 2017
they said next year which would have
been 2018 all of 2018 past we kind of
held our breaths and obviously nothing
happened no apparently interesting fact
at these Apple events you know there's
typically a hands-on area where if they
announce new products that's where you
can get your first time to get footage
of it I was there at that event I spent
all my time with the new iPhones air
power was also in that hands-on area but
if you go back and look at those videos
from 2017 people were in there people
were recording it but nobody was
actually able to get anything to work
people using air power in their videos
were putting things on the mat and they
just weren't charging so that was maybe
the first sign things weren't exactly
going to plan so a couple weeks go by
a couple months go by and eventually
were getting into 2018 and people start
to wonder as we don't hear anything when
air power is coming out is it gonna be
with a new product alongside something
else is gonna be its own separate thing
or they're just gonna silently put it on
sale and then slowly
one by one piece by piece Apple started
to remove air power from their site they
removed the official listing they
removed references to it from other
listings they just slowly started to
erase air power from the internet but as
you know you can't really erase
something from the internet it kind of
has the opposite effect so when that
started happening everyone started
finding that and writing articles about
any last traces of anywhere you could
find air power all the way up until a
couple days ago when they just started
shipping air pods to in those wireless
charging cases air power was still
mentioned on the box and if you buy even
to this day ear pods wireless charging
case there's a diagram of air power on
the back of it so every time someone
found something like this or some
updated code in iOS that mentioned air
power there would be some little glimmer
of hope that maybe we're actually gonna
see this product but also hopes were
kind of dashed everytime then in
September of 2018 so a whole year after
the announcement people still wondering
where it was John Gruber who is awesome
and a noted Apple insider in a very
reliable source all the time wrote on
his site what I've heard third hand but
for multiple little birdies is that air
power really is well and truly thought
something about the multi coil design
getting too hot way too hot so there are
engineers who looked at air powers
original design who said it could never
work thermally and now those engineers
have it told you so smug look on their
faces last year Apple was apparently
swayed by arguments that they could
figure out a way to make it work without
getting hot and they were clearly wrong
so that was one of many reports that
seem to point to engineering problems
with air power so what is this multi
coil design why is this such a problem
so apparently the big feature of air
power was not just that it's a wireless
charging that for three things but that
you could place any one of these three
things down anywhere on the mat and it
would detect what it was and just start
charging now I feel like me and you used
a typical wireless charger before that
process with one coil in the mat and one
coil and the phone can kind of be this
like awkward process of lining it up and
getting it just right for it to start
charging and if it's off or if you bump
it and you wake up the next morning and
you'd bumped it off the coil it wouldn't
have charged and some larger mats have
had up to three coils for you know three
different hot spots for charging three
different things at once but generally
Apple
wanted to basically reinvent this way of
wireless charging we wanted to add their
own magic touch to it so there are
comments now from people in this
industry saying that air power was
rumored to have anywhere from 20 to 30
plus coils in that one mat that allowed
for total XY freedom so you could put it
anywhere on the mat and it would pick
the nearest coil and be close enough to
charge but 20 to 30 coils in in one mass
so clearly thermal issues through that
whole process and with that whole idea
had it not working it's just too small
of a space and just Apple and thermals
just don't seem to get along especially
lately so basically Apple then had two
options at that point and this was last
year but at this point they could either
change air power like you can't have 20
to 30 coils in this small the space so
you can change it or you can just cancel
it and now in March 2019 finally Apple's
admitted this isn't gonna work
they're not gonna rebrand it they're not
gonna restructure this project they
cancelled it and I guess that's pretty
Apple like that they would rather cancel
the whole project then make a different
wireless charging that speaking of which
there are plenty of other Qi wireless
charging pads all over the internet
nomads sent me this one but I've had it
for a while and used it at home it's
their wireless charging hub you can
charge all three things at once
the Apple watch kind of goes up top but
you know same thing it works it's not
like a white orb or anything but
apparently they went immediately out of
stock of these as soon as that sort of
news hit that air power wasn't happening
so it's backward on this site but I'll
leave an Amazon link below for stuff
like this I don't think that many people
were actually going to buy air power
it's not like a game changer for them
it's not like they cancel the iPhone 11
or something or cancel the Mac Pro why
please don't cancel the Mac Pro by the
way oh my god they could cancel the Mac
Pro Apple is canceling unannounced
products the the Mac Pro is unannounced
they could cancel the Mac Pro they're
not gonna cancel the Mac Pro it's too
important nobody buys the Mac Pro though
please don't oh my god anyway bottom
line it wasn't a huge deal because of
how small the product it was I think it
would have been maybe 180 bucks maybe
around 200 bucks but we could be either
mad at Apple for not shipping a product
that they promised to ship that's pretty
weird not a good look at all
but also we can be glad that they didn't
ship something that would have been
dangerous for thermal reasons like maybe
a samsung maybe has in the past maybe
let me know which can't be R in if
you're kind of bummed that air power is
not happening or if you're just having a
laugh at Apple for not shipping
something they promised they would but
there you go now you know way too much
about a product that doesn't exist in
the timeline and the history and
everything that went into it but that's
been it hope you enjoyed thanks for
watching catch you guys in the next one
peace I'm over here nervous about this
Mac Pro the pre-announced Mac Pro
imagine they canceled it for thermal
reasons oh my god